before we start let me allow me to say
that I am deeply saddened by the recent
terrible shipwreck off the coast of
Italy the claim that lines the lives of
over 70 people including several
children
a wish to extend my deep felt
condolences to the families and friends
of those who lost their lives in this
tragic event
sadly this was not an instant isolated
event over the past years thousands and
thousands of people many of them young
children have lost their lives in
attempt to reach Europe
this tragedy serves a stock reminder
that saving lives at Sea is not only a
legal obligation but also a humanitarian
and moral imperative
these strategies also serve a brutal
reminder of the need to take political
action moving forward on the migration
pact an increased external action is
imperative
fighting trafficking and smuggling is a
priority
a joint Europeans response is necessary
this is a broad agreement at the council
that we need to adopt effect that we
need to adopt effective and Lasting
solutions to address the immediate and
ongoing challenges on all rules
including the center Central
Mediterranean route
in this regard the European Council
recognized and I quote the specificities
of Maritime borders including as regards
to safeguarding lives
it also underlines the need for
reinforced cooperation regarding social
rescues activities
let me now say a few words on some of
the main lines of action that the EU is
persuading we welcome the relaunch on
the European contact group on research
on social Rescue by the European
Commission
several member states are engaged in
discussions to set up an enhanced
cooperation framework for search and
rescue amongst Source actors including
international human humanitarian and
Maritime organizations
we also need to move forward with the
work to partnership with third countries
along the routes increasing capacities
in Border and Asylum management
providing Financial financial support
and Technical and material assistance in
ongoing in is ongoing in many partner
partner countries this work will
continue and we will step up where it is
feasible
in this context it is important to
recall that the effective protection of
the Schengen external borders is not
contrary to respect of the for the
values and fundamental rights in the EU
indeed our Frontline Frontline member
states have not only the right but also
the duty to protect the the European
borders this is a common responsibility
and we manage despite the considerable
difficulties and challenges that we
faced with
naturally in carrying carrying out these
duties schenging borders codes must be
applied in accordance with the European
and international law
honorable members safe and legal
migration is also a central part of our
comprehensive approach to migration with
almost 3 million Third Country National
migration to the EU every day every year
the opportunities clearly exist
s these legal Pathways have the
potential to benefit migrants countries
of a region as well as countries of
destination
legal Pathways also contribute towards
reducing irregular departures and
consequently saving lives at sea
when it comes to those most vulnerable
Our member states have shown that they
are committed to stepping up their
efforts in particular by way of
resettlement
since 2015 successful EU sponsored
resettlement schemes and humanitarian
admissions programs have helped more
than 130 000 people in need of
international protection to find shelter
in Our member states
I should also mention the steps forward
taken by both the both
co-legislators towards an agreement on
the union resettlement framework
regulation
as as a result we will finally be able
to move from ad hoc resettlement schemes
to be to a stable framework with greater
sustainability and predictability for
the protection for those who need
honorable members the EU needs a
comprehensive migration policy that that
protects our borders provide protection
to those who need in need and prevents
the loss of migrants lives I outlined
not today a number of areas on which we
are working it is the combination of
these different stamps of actions that
will ultimately ultimately bring our
bulk results thank you very much for the
attention I'm looking forward to the
debate
that's the dunk thank you very much
Madam president of the council
um Johansson commissioner you have the
floor
imagine you're a woman
and all you want is a better life for
your child
you think your only choice is to go on a
very dangerous Journey
imagine how high the waves
how small the boat
how crowded
how ice cold the wind
the pouring rain
imagine the fear
imagine the terror
that you might not be saved
and all because you have not find legal
way of coming to the European Union
since this Parliament put this debate on
the agenda yet another tragedy at Sea 30
people missing presumed round
behind the numbers
there are people human beings
like Shahid arasa she was 27 years old
from Pakistan
she was such a woman all she wanted was
to care for her disabled son Hassan
she could not come legally she thought
she's one of them more than 80 people as
far as we know who died in the waters of
Calabria
on February 26th
the price of her life
8 000 Euros
The Smuggler's fee
blood blood Money
the Shipwreck apparently happened when
the Smugglers steered The Vessel onto
shallow ground the Smugglers Abandoned
Ship leaving their passengers to their
fate
this tragedy must be a call to action
our first priority
save lives
our alternative
safe and legal pathways
our mission fight the Smugglers who
ruthlessly endanger people's lives
we must work relentlessly to bring them
to justice we always one step ahead
fighting smuggling is Central to our
action plan on the central Mediterranean
we must step up the fight as team Europe
with member states
we are building Partnerships to fight
smuggling supporting joint
investigations between member states and
North African Partners I will soon
travel to Tunisia where as you know the
situation is of concern
to boost our joint fight against
Smugglers and strengthen our
comprehensive migration partnership
and we must do more to prevent irregular
departures stop people getting into
Smuggler's boats and risking their lives
at sea
but we need migration
but in a regular way safe ways legal
Pathways we must work as team Europe
with countries of origin Transit and
destination to manage migration jointly
with our partners along the routes
including the central Mediterranean
to save lives we also need to work
better together
coordination is at the heart of the new
European integrated border management
strategy that the commission adopted
yesterday
based on your valuable input from this
house
and we relaunch the European contact
group on search and rescue I welcome the
active participation of member states
who are now working to improve
situational awareness and cooperation at
sea
foreign
but we need also to give people
alternatives to Smugglers boats and
trucks legal migration for those who
want to work our societies and economies
need skilled labor Health Care alone
lacks 2 million professionals today
so we are setting up an ambitious new
talent pool to help people enter into
the EU safely and legally
and we're working on the talent
Partnerships so people can learn and
work in key sectors in member states
and we would provide legal Pathways for
refugees safe Journeys to Safe homes
resettlement a humanitarian corridors
for 50 000 people in the next two years
supported by at least half a billion
euros
we are linking Community sponsorship of
refugees to work
by supporting companies with a targeted
funding call to employ refugees now
living in camps and in limbo
we have already successfully adopted the
new blue card and I encourage that
Kool-Aid co-legislators to make progress
and adopt the two Legacy proposal on the
single permit directive and the
long-term residence directive
in the letter from president vonder lion
to the leaders she outlined the key
operational actions on migration we are
taking already now
she will update the Council on progress
next week
all of these policies and operations are
important
but will only be truly effective as part
of the European migration policy
I am encouraged by the DHA Council last
week where ministers from across the EU
committed to adopt the whole pact on
migration and Asylum during this mandate
by the Swedish presidency committed to
start dialogues already in June on the
central pieces on solidarity and
responsibility including the special
category for the search and rescue cases
on relocation
and of course by the progress this house
is making by adopting the mandates on
the key packed files I hope already this
month
select these strategies at CE remind us
migration challenges need a European
response to save lives to manage
migration to fight Smugglers to open
safe and legal pathways I'm fully aware
that you in this house already know this
we need to work together to find
Solutions and to agree on The Pact thank
you
may I see Martin commissioner thank you
madam commissioner Sharon
yes thank you Mr Vice President every
death at Sea is an unspeakable tragedy
men women and children losing their
lives in the Mediterranean is truly
heartbreaking and yes we need as this
debate's title suggests a common EU
response and it starts by breaking the
lucrative business model that Smugglers
have built at the expense of vulnerable
people we need to fight against these
ruthless criminals who put hundreds of
people on far too small unseaworthy
vessels in the most difficult of
conditions at Sea thank God luckily most
people are safe like the 1300 people
last weekend but for some like the more
than 70 people that perished off the
coast of Calabria help tragically came
too late we need a fundamental change of
policy no matter how many search and
rescue operations are deployed at CF
hundreds of thousands of people continue
to embark on this dangerous Journey help
will never be able to reach all of them
on time arrivals by sea in Italy have
increased three times compared to last
year it means the risk of accidents has
also tripled so we need a common but
also a holistic approach no
oversimplification of complex challenges
by focusing on one solution only most
Asylum Seekers arriving in Europe are
not in need of international protection
and they will most likely continue to
risk their lives to come here
irregularly regardless of the legal
Pathways we put in place for those who
need it at least until we change the
automatism that paying a Smuggler equals
entry to the territory of the European
Union changing that needs to be the core
of the policy Europe finally adopts
because there is no Silver Bullet
fighting Smugglers creating Pathways
code of conducts for search and rescue
strengthening external borders
discouraging illegal migrations
improving cooperation with third
countries increasing returns these are
all intertwined they're all part of the
same puzzle and we need to complete this
whole puzzle we need to adopt the
migration pact in full if we want to
make debates like the one today a thing
of the past thank you
thank you very much
our next speaker
is the
snds
thank you president
eight years after the humanitarian
crisis of 2015 the European Union has
still not come up with a solution to
this most divisive common challenge
facing us all today the uh ship going
down in Calabria off Calabria because of
Maloney's uh
attitude and non-action Rob robberies
and assaults by a Greek border guards
these are the latest episodes in our
shameful policy of the governments of
Italy and Greece and the commission are
obliged to not just investigate these uh
circumstances but to come up with
measures that prevent this kind of abuse
in the 10 years that have elapsed
between
the uh tragedies of lampedusa and
Calabria more than 26 23 000 people have
died in the Mediterranean these are
years of frustrated negotiations of
blockage
and now instead of making progress
towards coming up with a new migration
as I'll impact the right wing prefers to
debate on whether to build walls at our
external borders in Europe and who
should pay for them it's been shown that
the worst kind of uh malls are the walls
in the mines of the right wing this is a
step back towards the reactionary
exclusive form of Europe
a view that tends to oppress knowledge
and a foster selfishness we need to
recover the Dignity of Europe and the
idea of walls is there's a false magic
sort of approach by Ultra nationalists
who was to present foreigners as as a
threat dividing us
and the many Asylum requests
presented last year also show that there
will be there can be no all that will
prevent people trying to flee disasters
and persecution
walls against this will not do away with
humans survival Instinct it would just a
matter of it be a matter of increasing
illegal migration and enriching the uh
gangs the people Smugglers
this phenomenon
can't be managed through a false
inefficient measures we need an integral
policy based on solidarity and shared
responsibilities as is contained in the
uh draft new migration and Asylum pact
which gives rights to refugees favors
the integration of refugees and fosters
the use of legal routes for integration
of refugees including visas employment
humanitarian Visas so this is a
challenge to Europe
not just vis-a-vis a specific policy but
in regard to our actual foundational
values thank you
this is
yes thank you chair uh first of all I
would like to thank the commissioner for
her words I think as a parliament which
should endorse your uh your course your
line of action you said commissioner
imagine you are one of those people and
I think this is where the problem begins
we have dehumanized those people
we cannot imagine anymore what it feels
like because we have dehumanized them it
always strikes me how we are talking
about an amount of migrants rather than
a number of migrants a number of
migrants is about individuals let's
start and go back to our humanity and
think of them as people I entirely agree
with my Epp colleague who said no
oversimplification of complex problems
that is why I have a bit of difficulty
understanding why the Epp is always
coming up with fake simplified Solutions
like walls around Europe it doesn't work
okay
yeah it may work in an electoral
campaign but it doesn't work at all in
solving the problem
the renew group has written through the
European Council and called for Swift
action because we do think that the GHA
Council now has to move yes we are
working on The Pact it's very difficult
but we hope we will get there but that
is not going to solve the problem today
the people who are getting on boats
today need to be helped and that is why
we need sufficient and adequate rescue
capacity organized by the member states
and the European Union thank you
thank you
Mr Eric marcrot is the next speaker
yes
thank you very much president
I think that some people are right
the Smugglers
maybe evil people
and for the wrong motivations they send
people on a very dangerous route and
people die as a result
um but we're not here because of these
Smugglers being bad people we're here
because people in distress at Sea have
not been rescued when they could have
been that happened
on on Saturday 2 A.M in the morning
distress calls were put out
and no one came to help for 30 hours no
assistance was sent in international
waters the Irina Mission could have been
the ngos could have been there the
merchant vessels could have been there
and saved these people but no one was
told or given the task of rescuing those
people and if we take things seriously
that the Dignity of individuals is
inalienable inalienable we cannot just
blame the Smugglers before the bodies
are buried always saying that other
people are to blame we need to take the
core of the debate seriously if someone
is in distress at Sea let us send rescue
boats and rescue these people for
whatever reason they're in distress and
the fact that that doesn't happen is a
shame for Europe we should be ashamed we
shouldn't just stick to fine words we
need to start start acting otherwise we
will have to assume that future
Generations will continue consider us
bad people and what is
thank you Mr Vincenzo so far is next
only tragedy
we've seen what's happened what's with
the left they've accused uh uh
prime minister Maloney of having blood
on our hands
we've seen hundreds of thousands of
people who are victims of uh people
Smugglers and who's
seen what happened as they get shoved
onto boats which are likely to sink but
the hope that they are going to be able
to count on the health Avengers when
they are
when they found her at Sea of course
borders we have border instruments to
try and help but they don't go far
enough when we've seen what's happened
with the frontix if we think about the
moral responsibilities of the tragedies
well we could debate that at length but
our duty is to think about urgent
solutions for uncontrollable migration
flows
these are solutions which the commission
is finally beginning to see and they've
taken up our requests it to strengthen
frontex and to uh
carry out a more robust returns
there will be the upcoming uh reform of
the uh Dublin of Dublin as well and
that's something that we'll be looking
at when it comes up and so we need I
think as well to try and strengthen our
external borders so that it's not just
about redistributing those that manage
to survive the trip let's see but also
to try and dissuade them from taking to
the boats in the first place thank you
Godzilla thank you
Analisa tardino is the next speaker
they left in this Parliament and outside
continues to seek scapegoats for the
deaths at Sea and they've even accused a
prime minister Maloney and Deputy Prime
Minister salvini and the Italian Coast
Guard and rather than
accepting that they are involved in
saving people but no one thought of
blaming Sanchez for the Malia tragedy
and the um
the parties to blame are the people of
Smugglers and the do-gooders and it is
ah due to your duty to stop the people
traffickers as the pope has said that is
what our political energy should be
directed at we should be absolutely firm
and show no Indulgence towards these
criminals and we hope that at the next
Council the Europe Europe will put
forward positive actions to combat
traffickers stop deaths at Sea and
protect our borders the cultural tragedy
is just as symbolic of a tragedy it took
which has gone on for a number of years
and
we need to stop this at the root and a
good politics means taking
responsibility for making decisions
rather than passing the buck at two
countries such as Italy thank you
is next
Tuesday
thank you very much 26
000 people have died in the
Mediterranean
since 2014.
if we realize this then we also have to
realize that we need a response we need
to have more efforts in uh to save lives
however governments are continuing to
misuse
solidarity and we can't accept this so
what does the commission tend to intend
to do what does the presidency intend to
do to avoid this to stop people from
drowning
the model used by people traffickers
focuses on people who have no other
alternative we have to act but we don't
have
enough posts available we need to see
more work more effort from member states
these dangerous Journeys will continue
because people are being forced to leave
their homes in countries like
Afghanistan Iran and Syria
so we're we are very clear
we don't want borders to be closed off
with walls this is not the correct
response we have to see coordinated
efforts from the European Union we have
to provide Aid and support
today all of these efforts are focused
on uh controlling borders we're seeing
an increase in mortality by these um by
these dangerous ways to access Europe we
need to see more solidarity to save
lives
thank you very much president the
Mediterranean
always seems to be more similar now to a
watery Cemetery
26 000 dead since 2015.
uh and there is that lack of legal
Pathways to the European Union they come
to the European Union fleeing from
conflict fleeing from Strife it's clear
that saving lives at Sea is an
obligation moral and legal for all
member states of the European Union
uh search and rescue can has to be the
job of everybody not just the coastal
countries all member states of the
European Union have to display Humanity
uh with a minister of internal affairs
in Italy who has been accused of lack of
sensibility sensitivity uh and a lack of
understanding uh for these people a
government which has displayed huge
inhumanity what
thank you very much
it is clear
whether it's National International or
European European it's it's an
obligation
but these dangerous Journeys are the
consequence not the cause
it's right that the presidency is
focusing on cooperation with countries
of origin and Transit Transit we need to
improve
conditions there on the ground we need
to combat criminal networks and this
very cynical business model it's not
easy to bring three institutions
together and 27 member states
we all know that
but we will
be judged on whether we are able to
contribute to handling the situation and
whether we're able to end this situation
deep packed
can it will not be a miracle but it will
be able to
um increase confidence and what's we've
seen in the past few weeks is a common
approach by the EU has its effect
and
we
this
the The
Proposal on legal ways
could perhaps be the um best way
in 2021 I had a very similar speech and
it's good that we're talking about this
but we this year we need to deliver
given the uh increased
we need more Europe now and it's this is
urgent therefore I call on you and
perhaps especially this week
it was too easy in the past to criticize
the council now we almost also need to
deliver what we do not have is time
thank you
thank you for colleaguing well thank you
very much Colleen then now
foreign
we very much hope to see an asylum and
migration pact in order to see some
effective solidarity we all hope to see
that however quite honestly
I I'm quite tired of hearing Europe
always being be blamed because
I have never seen an extreme right
government asking for European
competencies to be strengthened when it
comes to migration whereas I've seen
plenty of left governments uh I've seen
plenty of them sorry ask for more money
for building walls and if you look at
um
salvini and Maloney they repeat nativist
slogans against migrants neo-colonial
um
slogans send them all back home uh
slogan saying that you migrants are
coming to Europe to try to um substitute
European people racist slogans
and facing these uh tragedies of
innocent people what do we do we hear
people saying that Europe isn't doing
enough well that's all very easy
they can create a new crime
um you know say they're going to hunt
out these uh
uh traffickers
um across the waters all around the
world but what about
um
supporting the Coast Guard when actually
the state itself who has raised
obstacles to saving people at Sea this
itself is a crime just like the
traffickers are committing a crime and
then finally uh we see them singing
karaoke songs for salvini's birthday and
they don't even care that people are
dying
please if you care about Italy stop
bringing Shane shame upon us and take
your responsibility
[Applause]
thank you very much president uh major
Hansen commission and Minister Jessica
Roswell
the Shipwreck at near Koto in Italy is
shocking for all of us precisely because
this
um
vote sank in European Waters not high
seas but this vote was reported to the
Italian Coast Guard more than 60 people
died and um 2 300 in the Mediterranean
last year we cannot
um
turn away from this uh crisis with my uh
renew colleagues were calling for our
sea rescue mission and European level
and we need to have legal ways of
migration as well in the medium and long
term our response is the Asylum and
migration pact which allows us to
provide a harmonized Asylum rules in the
European Union and a solidarity
mechanism for member states time is
running out I call on the council the
commission
please we need to accelerate our work so
that we're able to make progress on this
reform we've been waiting for for a long
time thank you very much
[Applause]
the Mediterranean Sea is the deadliest
migration route in the world and this is
not a law by Nature it's caused by
mankind
by the political decision to ignore
search and rescue obligations shift
responsibility to the Libyan Coast Guard
obstruct the work of NGO saving lives
this is a policy of deliberate
disengagement a lack of solidarity and a
Shameless evasion of One's Own
obligations
and the response to every tragedy is
giving more boats to the Libyan Coast
Guard meaning more people contained in
hell
but where are the genuine life jackets
where is an EU coordinated search a
rescue mechanism where's the mandatory
relocation for rescued Asylum Seekers
where is the protection for humanitarian
workers and where are the safe and legal
migration routes where is the display of
humanity
so counseling commission stop this
deadly tactic of looking away and
fencing off and hold up the fundament of
the EU namely our values thank you
thank you very much Herman Terrace you
have the floor please thank you
death at Sea is a drama but many of
these tragedies are avoidable and some
are part of that major trafficking
operation towards Europe
so Nations have to protect their borders
we need controlled migration
otherwise we have people just going out
at Sea and leaving their lives to the
fate of traffickers
it's not only criminal circles and
organizations that profit from all of
this their collaborators are a number of
different a humanitarian organizations
which are manipulated by the far left
some of you here actually
and they are part of this human
trafficking operation leaving people at
Sea it's a kind of uh if you like
um
element that is related to the slave
trade of centuries past
so it is all part of a cycle of violence
all of this in order to get cheap labor
if you want to stop death at Sea well
Georgia Maloney shows us the path
she shows us the path and that means
prison for traffickers and getting rid
of this entire Scourge altogether with
proper legislation
foreign
colleagues in 2022
frontex flagged up over 330 illegal
Crossings towards Europe and 90 of those
involved traffickers
once people have got to Europe they can
enjoy Social Security that we've created
that's paid for by our taxpayers without
having to have contributed to it
themselves
all they have to do is ask for Asylum
these aren't real refugees
they're just people coming to seek their
Fortune over here
and yet what does Europe do to protect
people from here nothing quite the
opposite
we make life easier to get for people to
cross to Europe
we need an alternative to this illegal
policy anyone who comes illegally to
Europe should lose all rights to Asylum
and should have a lifetime ban of coming
to Europe the right to Asylum doesn't
mean they have a right to reside
we should ensure that when we welcome
them respect the rules
you have the floor
I couldn't disagree with what you said
Madame Johansson under any circumstance
whatsoever however we here see that we
have two europes one which Europe which
doesn't understand and one which
realizes what the situation is speaking
about Italy about that shipwreck what
we're speaking about key theater that
island that shipwreck there uh just two
months ago boats leaving from Izmir from
turkey and then crashing upon the rocks
on githira on that island in Greece
didn't anybody see them didn't frontex
see them didn't anybody see them at all
the Coast Guard so I think we've seen
numerous cases like this from January
until June of 2022 an average of five
people die a day trying to cross our
seas the Mediterranean Sea
uh according to the unhcr the total
number of dead or missing in the
Mediterranean in 2022 is more than 1 200
and international law what it says well
we've been talking about it for years
that we need safe passage and we need
legal migration we agree absolutely with
you does the right agree with you as
well it appears that they don't seem to
understand we have on many occasions
traffickers right under our noses right
under the noses of national authorities
under the nose of affrontex as well
that's why I mentioned the case of key
theater
said the other Jay it was a wonderful
speech he said we are the generation of
politicians who cannot ignore this
reality
well let's not just describe the
situation let's legislate because we
have a very serious situation here so to
close incorporation relocation and of
course safe Pathways thank you merci
Nicolas pay
Mr Nicholas bye please colleagues
while the United Kingdom is finally
announcing firm Majesty fight illegal
immigration while Italy is predicting an
invasion in Europe it needs to do all it
can to protect its borders while ngos
are accomplices of human traffickers
while your delays your lacks approach
your your cowardice are responsible for
that honestly you want to go further and
further the same causes produce the same
effect the same words of openness and
welcome push more and more migrants to
leave and sometimes die at sea if you
had a little bit of humanity real
Humanity you would dissuade them from
leaving
so stop trying to project that there is
an El Dorado which does not exist stop
encouraging them to come to Europe and
risk their lives you are pushing them
into the hands of mafias of um
traffic as you are uprooting them far
from their families in their countries
real humanity is being firmer migration
your lacks approach is shameful and it's
guilt and you're guilty because of that
our next speaker isolino
Presidente thank you president I had one
speech prepared of a miniature but I'm
going to make another speech a one
minute speech it's shameful it's
shameful to hear from Italians who are
using uh deaths to speak out against a
government the kutral tragedy is not an
Italian tragedy it's a European tragedy
and the solutions have to be European
why do we never talk about the children
who disappear and other things that
happen in Italy do you understand how
complicated it is Italy doesn't leave
anyone on their own no one in Europe
can
um
permit themselves to leave Italy on its
own either sixty thousand migrants have
been solved saved by the uh Coast Guard
and who's doing that we're talking about
increases in of 250 percent from Tunisia
and Libya and from around Turkey
and we have to talk about this we can't
just draw a veil over this over a member
state that deserves to be helped from
all of us we are Europe it's not that
you have Italy on one side in Europe on
the other so what I'm hearing here is
honestly it's shameful
you're not honoring and respecting the
thousands of victims the sacrifice of
human life These are something that we
are all responsible for we have to
respect them but you on the left don't
do so
it's as if I'm saying uh ngos are
exploiting human lives and migrants
is that not right
thank you Mr Lopez Aguilar please
thank you very much
Commerce commissioner this is the fifth
debate in the European Parliament about
deaths at Sea in the European Union and
the call for a mechanism uh rescue
search and rescue mechanism uh and this
last shipwreck in near crotone in
Calabria
there were 200 people on board that boat
over 200 people and frontex had informed
had informed fishing vessels near that
boat that what was happening but the
government of Georgia Meloni has made
the lives of ngos impossible the
consequence is is that nobody intervened
neither a fishing vessel nor the Coast
Guard of the Italian authorities nobody
could help to save those individuals
in distress
of all those victims 18 were children
26 000 deaths in the Mediterranean in
these last years from Syria Afghanistan
Iraq Somalia uh you name it individuals
who have been tortured individuals who
were trying to find their way nothing
nothing has been done for them we need
solidarity effective solidarity and we
need to work we need to have binding
systems in place to allow for safe
Pathways we need a proper mechanism
right now of this European Parliament
cannot stop cannot rest until all the
member states
abide to some sort of system to save
these individuals we need a European
mechanism for search and rescue and we
need European humanitarian visas for
these individuals
thank you very much sir
president thank you very much president
colleagues
obviously it is the state's job to
rescue people and we have um spent too
long leaving this to ngos it was very
dramatic what we've seen in
Mediterranean and it's even more
dramatic because it took place in
European Waters in Italian Waters but
colleagues what we really need is not
just a solution for sea rescue where we
do need a solution and what we need is
um
is is to take a big step because in the
um we're going to vote in the committee
this month and all of the uh migration
files and so that we can deliver and so
that citizens can get what they expect
that is finally a solution on migration
issue so that there are European
responses to this issue the council
needs to get the member states moving
and everyone always tries to reach the
maximum in their positions now everyone
needs to be prepared to compromise four
crises we need a solution for the
successor to Dublin and we need to do
this because if we don't if we don't
have proposals which we can negotiate on
to in order to be able to legislate
colleagues then citizens will rightly
say you didn't manage to do anything
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much no
the floor goes to Madame Grace
O'Sullivan
colleagues in the late 1980s I first saw
someone drowning at Sea I was a crew
member on board a Greenpeace ship and we
were on a campaign in the Mediterranean
Sea just off Mallorca
people often think of the Mediterranean
as a calmsi but that night a ferocious
storm was raging when we answered a
Mayday call
a Sailing Boat was going down in
extremely rough conditions we did
everything we could hauling the crew on
board as the boat was sinking before our
very eyes
two made it two did not
saving lives at Sea is a duty
and Europe is failing to uphold that
Duty
by closing legal Pathways with illegal
pushbacks by persecuting
humanitarians the distress calls are
still coming in
it's time that we answer them it's time
we answer them now
thank you
um
thank you very much presidents minister
during these days we've seen a
terrible uh defamatory campaign against
the government of Italy against Italy uh
saying that the the government is
totally impassive asleep at night is
what people have said on the left as
well
now the death of so many desperate
people how do you sleep at night is what
has been said that the that the fight
against traffickers that it how how do
you sleep at night if you don't fight
against traffickers
yesterday you'll have heard about the uh
what has been done by the Spanish
government how do you sleep at night
many many years nothing has been done
against trafficking and traffickers how
do you sleep at night I ask legislators
in the European Parliament I ask all
these Hypocrites everywhere how do you
sleep at now without having done
something against trafficking
foreign
responsibility
let's face up to our responsibilities
it's because you're encouraging migrants
to carry out these dangerous clandestine
crossings that they're dying at Sea
you're constantly calling for
immigration you support the principle of
non-return you provide assurances to to
understand migrants that they will never
be sent back to their countries
so yet 90 of homeless people in France
are not covered are not covered cared
for and yet ngos are complicit in all of
this this is all your responsibility
the only way to prevent these deaths
is to ensure that migrants understand
that they should not be tempted to take
undertake The Crossing we won't take
them in that's what Australia did in
2015 and reduce the number of deaths at
Sea to zero that's what the United
Kingdom wants to do
and what pushed the Brits to brexit and
it's the only way to deal with it to
stop people from risking their lives
it's the only way to prevent the planned
disappearance of our civilization under
this wave of migrants thank you
merci thank you very much
sir Martin please hi president
foreign thank you very much president
commissioner
colleagues obviously seeing more and
more terrible tragedies in Mediterranean
thousands of people on the dangerous
route to Europe have lost their lives if
we want to talk about sea rescue we say
it's not a solution no it's part of the
problem it's partly it's partly
responsible every activist who sees
themselves as a rescuer in the
Mediterranean does the same things as
the um the lobby and the traffickers
because desperate people are coming from
the Middle East and Africa to come to
Europe illegally
and they are risking their lives across
the sea you have the full responsibility
for this human suffering at our external
borders and I would like to say with
this lethal practice we need to bring
this lethal practice to an end we can
only have one message from the EU and
that is illegal migration in the EU has
no chance it is not tolerated and only
by doing that will we strengthen our
external borders and where we combat the
trafficking mafias and we'll stop people
from from um drowning
okay please
[Music]
this is a repetitive debate and last
time we had it in this very chamber we
were discussing whether rescues of lives
at Sea encourages people to travel and
seek refuge in Europe Barry Andrews my
colleague from renew said that there is
evidence that this is not the case do
you have evidence for your claim that
you just made that rescue at Sea
encourages people to travel across the
Mediterranean
it is it is quite clear if they have the
opportunity to come to Europe this way
they will do it it's just evidence
nothing else so it's quite easy if there
is no more chance to come in this way
they won't do it anymore
it's the Australian way you know and
that would be a solution that not so
many people must die in the
Mediterranean as they do at the time so
we must change this by saying no not
this way I'm not at all against legal
kind of migration
but not in an illegal way which leads
people directly into death by drowning
next speaker is
thank you very much during the November
plenary here in this room and I and
other colleagues with the council and
commission here the proposal was
presented about trafficking of human
being beings death at Sea and safe
pathways
so there's of course our particular
position
it was very very clear and the
Parliament repeatedly has expressed that
there's a need for orderly migration
this is an issue which has become
dramatically even more important we have
to find some sort of joint solution now
my question is how many more times are
we going to have to discuss this how
many more deaths are we going to have to
see the cutro uh shipwreck showed once
again that unfortunately Italy became
the stage of a tragedy but it is not an
Italian tragedy it is a European tragedy
there's not a migratory emergency in
Italy there's a migratory emergency
throughout Europe
so the issue of migration ought to be
put on the top of the next Council
agenda Italy cannot be left alone we
need a United Europe which will act in
solidarity in a concerted fashion
trafficking of human beings has to be
dealt with effectively finally we have
to also have legal Pathways deal with
the countries of origin deal with the
place of disembarkation as well in an
effective fashion but Europe has to work
together otherwise it will be negligent
thank you very much president
Council and colleagues from the Epp
women men and children who are risking
their lives to cross Mediterranean
knowing that so many people die there
are doing so in utter desperation to be
able to escape from Hunger War ethic and
religious persecution in the home
countries
Mussolini from the Epp in particular
I'd say that restricting rescue
operations in Mediterranean and limiting
ngos is the opposite of what we should
do and what your government should do
what you is doing is is what it's doing
is in humane
you need to
stop traffic because it's not ngos that
are exploiting lives they save lives
and they need to save people who are
risking their lives because of
desperation
obviously European solidarity is very
important as well
but the
ministers in should you should stop
doing Italian propaganda
[Applause]
thank you president yes this is a
failure for Europe the fact that once
again today we're having to talk about
this today as people are dying in the
Mediterranean
when all they're looking for is security
and a best and a better future this is a
failure for the EU today I would like to
address Georgia Maloney who during her
election campaign declared that
as a woman and a Christian her heart was
burning for Italian values
is it possible in a Christian and
mother's heart is there any room for
people who are looking for protection
who are fleeing their backgrounds and no
apparently not
10 years ago when the lampedusa disaster
happened when the children's tiny bodies
were washing up on beaches then we all
said this should never happen again
we saw the body of a Kurdish child and
we all said never again and yet here we
are yet again
Ibrahim Salim was three years old
at Madina hassini was six years old
Alan Cody was two years old
these children old drowned thousands of
people are dying and this is a failure
for Europe
but our next speaker is Happy New York
Robert no yes Robert okay excuse me
indeed Hotel because
as if wanting to have border control has
been seen as something shameful
but the massive smuggling of individuals
that has been the result
borders are necessary for the welfare
and security of people in our member
states and massive human trafficking is
a terrible crime
the these people getting onto the boat
uh hoping that ngos will help them
somewhere along the way hope thereafter
that they'll end up in Europe
frontex has to protect the borders now
Asylum applicants okay can conduct those
in third countries those who are going
to come illegally to Europe will be sent
back that has to be the policy that we
adopt that will protect our member
Stakes we'll say member states will save
lives as well and will stop illegal
irregular migration
it is no solution to the problem
allowing these people into the country
and providing for them thereafter
excuse me for the irritation before
normally is
the floor
thank you very much president once again
we're seeing migrants drowning in the
Mediterranean and it's very clear that
the EU is to blame
because the the EU is not
um
combating this Mass migration and you
support these private sea Rescuers
and then
you're providing assistance to criminal
traffickers and the
EU is giving incentives to migrations to
reduce the death figures to zero
would be possible if we ban these
private traffickers and
and to have a state sea rescue which
take which drives all votes back and
takes people back to their countries of
origin
but this
but if if we want to reduce the death
figures 2-0 this is the only way all of
the other things
literally are about your crude ideology
of open borders and we will see more
hundreds and thousands of people
um uh dying and you are the ones to
blame thank you
now
Madame McGinnis I'd like to welcome you
at this particular point to this agenda
uh point that we're on and our next
speaker is um colleague riviere
president
thank you president
if reality wasn't so tragic if so many
people hadn't drowned in this dangerous
Crossing
it would uh be almost funny that we are
once again in this surreal discussion
of these uh facts being repeated
um France allows tens or hundreds of
thousands of migrants believe that they
including illegal migrants will think
that they'll be able to find houses and
jobs when they come over here the EU and
some member states
are continuing to subsidize ngos which
they themselves act as traffickers
European countries are drowning in
migration and
they can't uh continue like this unless
they're going to undermine uh their own
citizens security particularly the most
vulnerable
Europe has to give more means to frontex
and given the clear message that uh when
it comes to these boats they have to
accompany them back to where they came
from in order to avoid these terrible
human tragedies
thank you please thank you very much
president
at the beginning I wanted to express
my disappointment that the E is not able
being able to find a solution on legal
ways of
migration and people I've heard that
we're talking about people now so there
is a little bit of hope we see we have
managed to have the temporary protection
directive so 20 years after it was
adopted now can we could we actually
have a European rescue mechanism we said
for all advantages to this
now it it would help
to avoid the tragedies we've seen in the
Mediterranean and elsewhere
then we could welcome people in dignity
power in parallel we should also have
legal ways people to to migrate
and I think in this way Europe would
actually grow from this thank you
yeah cool thank you very much please
thank you very much colleagues
for once again for the upteenth time
we have those terrible images before our
eyes of what took place in kutra
women women
small children
coming to Europe with hope
this particular shipwreck
once again reveals a very very dark side
not all because of the law enforcement
authorities
there are clear decisional
responsibilities
the Italian government has not been able
to provide Solutions it has not been
able to resolve this particular
situation why
why would a mother and father take a
child on such a dangerous Journey
questions like that come to mind as well
what is the source of this particular
situation then the European Union what
sort of mechanisms are in place what
sort of mechanisms are necessary because
it's quite clear that the day after the
response is the same let's wait but when
we wait it is always too late thank you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
quite honestly
we have to
tell the truth
if we don't want to continue seeing
these Dreadful images of uh dead women
and men and children on our
Mediterranean beaches
we can't allow them we can't continue to
put dreams in these people's heads by
convincing them that if they come here
to Europe they will uh
meet everything that's been promised to
them for um
centuries Wars and famineers famines and
awful circumstances have pushed people
to migrate
and yet today
we have another Scourge that Scourge is
called Putin we know that the Wagner
group has used migrants as Weapons
against the European Union
and has a pushed them to cross-border
borders for example the Polish border we
have to
if you want to continue with tragedies
then just keep on doing what you're
doing but people's here but I cannot see
him at the moment is Mr hargreen and
David here
no so we come to the next speaker
what
speaker I asked only for the next
speaker but not to you Mr deuvo he's not
here
foreign
thank you very much dear colleagues
the shipwrecks on the Mediterranean are
heartbreaking human tragedies
blaming the legitimate Buddha protection
efforts of member states however is a
very dishonest and a completely wrong
approach
the underlying reason for these tragic
events in reality is the European
Indulgence and lack of sanction
concerning illegal entries into the
Union
it is the pro-migration statements the
quotas and the impunity for ngos that
cooperate with criminals Smugglers that
cause these deaths
Italy faces The Continuous arrival of
more and more ships with an estimated
650 000 people set to leave Africa just
this year as forecast by intelligence
services
it is European migration policy that
must be placed on a completely new
footing in order to avoid more human
tragedies at sea
Stop The Vicious Circle the first thing
to do is to start protecting Europe's
borders so that there would be no point
for Smugglers and migrants to even begin
their dangerous Journey also all
illegally arrived migrants in Europe who
have no right to stay must be
transported back home unless we do these
things there will be no end to the
tragedies that we have witnessed thank
you
thank you Mr Pedro patolo
thank you very much president the images
of uh cadavers on the coast of coutro
and both sinking coming from Libya
causes great great turbulence in me
indeed
we had those
380 dead that washed up on our Shores
not long ago all of this is a Europe
which cannot manage its migratory waves
it's shameful shameful deeply shameful
we cannot let bureaucratic procedure and
poor management lead to the loss of
lives we need the humanity of policy we
need to have systems in place where
there's a fundamental respect as well
remember your children your nephews your
nieces your grandchildren
just understand that we have to work
together as Parliament as counsel as
commission as well everything has to be
negotiated can be negotiated but not
life and not fundamental values thank
you
I will speak in in Dutch
[Music]
I listen very closely to what Mr Hansen
was saying in her presentation and I
think that it's full of good intentions
but these don't lead us anywhere
five days ago
14 people drowned just off the Tunisian
Coast that's two weeks after what
happened in Italy
there wasn't any particular
um
we're getting used to the fact that
there isn't much support from the
commission
currently there are 2 400 people who are
blocked in reception facilities is this
Humane I'm happy to hear that Mrs
Johansson will go to Tunisia but
um
she must not come back empty-handed
because it's in we need to destroy the
trafficking networks before they destroy
the lives of other people thank you
mucho
is
Italy beautiful Seas of Italy have
turned into a watery grave for women and
children we've seen that once again in
kutra and the Italian government wasn't
able to save the lives of children and
their parents
they have been accused these individuals
who have died have been accused and they
have been
um it is their Destiny has been their
own making this is totally shameful it
is not only the responsibility of Italy
but of all Europeans
um with Dublin to it was quite clear
that there were great problems that
existed and that all European Union
countries have to work together in order
to fight effectively to work effectively
in order to provide at least the bare
minimum for these individuals
so indeed everybody has to assume
responsibility and those people who are
getting money to take these people
across the seas it has to be understood
that this particular phenomena has to be
fought as well if we don't work in a
concerted fashion and effectively these
Waters will continue to be a cemetery
for many
thank you
president commissioner
a representatives of council colleagues
topekai amakal was an Afghan journalist
a pleasant woman committed and who loved
her job
however she hadn't been able to do her
job since the Taliban came to power she
only had one option to flee to Europe
two weeks ago she drowned off the coast
of Calabria topekai is one of five
members of her family who died at the
same time one of the tens of people who
have disappeared in the waves one of 26
000 people who have died in the
Mediterranean since 2014. topikai died
because the European Union did not
create safe roots
because Italy has undermined the work of
ngos ngos that are doing the work that
Italy doesn't want to do it doesn't want
to take its responsibility behind each
number is a story
and as long as EU policy tries only to
prevent refugees from coming in then new
stories will be added to hers we'll have
new stories to tell until heads of state
and government finally transform their
Hollow condolences into actions in order
to ensure real solidarity from Europe
thank you very much president once again
for the fifth time we're talking about
tragic deaths at sea between Africa and
Europe we need to tell the truth
migrants by boat will continue to die
as long as the EU continues with this
policy
in recent years
in Bangladesh the population has grown
to more than 40 million in 20 years 80
million in Pakistan how can we deal with
such migration pressure
because people come from these maybe
I'll come from these countries we need
to face the truth
in Australia you can see how things can
be done
we the only thing that will stop deaths
is to take another approach
otherwise we'd have completely open
borders is that what really you stand
for for karinaos thank you very much
Karina Olsen please
well all of this means that
these people these parents will not see
their children again those who died
let's not forget that these are families
that are torn apart let's not forget
that these individuals who perished have
families elsewhere as well these people
have risked their lives because there
are no legal Pathways to Europe and it
will continue as such
the destiny of these individuals will be
thrown into the
clutches of traffickers if we don't have
a system in place Pathways in other
words
we have to also stop pushing the buck
somewhere out there to somebody else we
are responsibility of responsible we
need a long-term sustainable migration
policy the right to Asylum has to be
there for people we have a responsible a
responsibility towards all these people
I have one I accept one blue card from
the ECR
book done
please decons because my speech would be
on Polish language
please take okay thank you
I'd like to ask you a question madam
Miss
Marco committed a huge error
translation do you have translation okay
please thank you Mr sir thank you
yes I wanted to ask you the question
Chancellor Merkel committed a huge error
in the past because she proposed a
mechanism to share the burden of
immigration in 2005 and that idea is
very popular on other continents and
this is why so many migrants come to
Europe should we not change attack
because we need to inform people eat
migrants in their countries that there's
no legal route to Europe not in that way
anyway
well thank you very much I'd like to
thank you very much for the question yes
uh another signal can be sent out and
that is that we need a long-term
sustainable migration policy and those
that have the right to Asylum that they
be able to apply for that and that they
are to be treated in a dignified fashion
it's important for all parties that they
all negotiate effectively so that we
have once again a long term sustainable
policy respecting human dignity our next
speaker is Mr angel jambatsky
illegal migration colleagues means
Crossing illegally state borders and
this means mean means breaking the law
and I'm astonished that the left part of
the chamber calls for support of
Breaking the Law of breaking the state
borders real support for the state and
organizations means support to organized
crime and support to people who are
violating the law this position is
contradictory ladies and gentlemen you
as stand for
supremacy of the law but you actually
provoke violating the law and
debts of people mean nothing to you
unless you gain political
profit thank you
[Music]
this brings us on to catch the high
I have a request from various political
groups eight in total
and
I will accept all eight as long as you
stick to the speaking time starting with
Thomas labs.com please
thank you in the attempt to reach Europe
since 2015
over 25 5 000 people died or gone
missing uh at the sea lots of migrants
paid traffickers in order to reach
Europe for criminal networks this is
quite profitable for example in 2015 it
is uh estimated that three to six
billion million euros
were gained by the criminal networks
however in order to address a
humanitarian disasters of people drying
drowning rescue operations are not
enough we need to have a joint European
uh response and we also need to increase
our cooperation with with uh third
countries in order to deal with this
issue at the source the EU does not have
the duty to receive all those who want
to come to our continent only because
the living standard is better here than
in their countries at the same time we
cannot just ah ignore the deaths of
thousands of people who couldn't reach
Europe in a legal way
thank you very much thank you very much
commissioner
now 30 deaths on Sunday a
and then in Calabria we've had a number
as well uh uh thousands last year these
are not just figures but what Mata
matsola said we cannot tolerate this in
the future
so how many more deaths actually do we
need how much more time are we going to
have to wait until uh binding
mechanism is in place let's not forget
the Sofia uh
mechanism that saved many uh
I think indeed we have to transcend the
horrible Narrative of hate of the
extreme right ladies and gentlemen of
the right
is there any drop of humanity in you to
work together for a fight against Mafia
a mafia against criminal Circle against
criminal circles against traffickers and
working in order to ameliorate the
situation in places of origin
but in the recent uh shipwreck the
Italian authorities refused to help and
the responsible Libyan authorities did
not help despite having received both
Patrol boats and millions of Euros from
the European Community this is why we
need to revoke the Libyan search and
rescue area and we need to have EU
state-led search and rescue we cannot
delegate the responsibility of refugees
at the EU borders to other states we
need to make sure that we have legal
Pathways both for refugees and for
migrants to the EU this is the only
solution to stop people from dying at
the European borders Our member states
need to take the responsibility for
helping refugees at the borders of the
EU we need to have proper Partnerships
with trustworthy countries so that we
can receive migrants and refugees
properly and dignified and so that we
can also send back the migrants try to
come to Europe under the guise of being
refugees thank you
thank you
Miranda
there's no bigger wall the native
dehumanization
and we've seen that and the lack of
solidarity in human it's a shame and a
scandal
we're here in the European Parliament
talking about this tragedy the death the
lack of legal ways of humanitarian
corridores of safe methods to get here
and how shameful is it to hear from the
right and the extreme right in this
chamber the Italian extreme right in the
Spanish extreme rat demonizing ngos who
are the only people saving lives at Sea
in European Seas we're hearing racist
hateful and xenophobic speeches speeches
that should not be accepted in a
parliament such as this one
colleagues there is no wall that can
keep out the despair
that can prevent people from wanting to
seek a better life we shouldn't be
talking about numbers or photographs of
dead bodies we're talking about um
people in their Human Condition whatever
that may be thank you thank you
Madame sardony Silvia
you are hypocrites
this is the responsibility of the
European Union the sole responsibility
and the policies that have been adopted
or failed to have been adopted have led
to increased arrivals to the European
Union
this has been a terrible burden a burden
for European citizens a tragedy for
migrants as well you speak about
Humanity so you just leave Italy all
alone with all that responsibility
seven billion Euro have been passed over
to erdogan and the disembarkations
continue from
turkey people continue to leave that
country we've become ridiculous there's
no European policy whatsoever and nobody
wants economic migrants
so enough of that propaganda with regard
to solidarity and working in a concerted
fashion we have to be serious at this
point
so this particular rhetoric and
hypocrisy with all of these death at Sea
how do you really actually sleep at
night
um
thanks very much president
we're talking about 26 000 lives lost in
the Mediterranean
and that's just the number of bodies
recovered God knows what the real figure
is
this is not just a tragedy
it is a preventable tragedy
this humanitarian crisis has been
created by neglectful and inhumane
policies member state border pushbacks
and the creation of frontex who have
carried out further illegal pushbacks
and have been complicit in severe human
rights violations
migrants desperately need safe legal
Pathways not arbitrary criminalization
for risking their lives in treacherous
conditions for a better future
remember there's many MEPS in here
voters for these migrants to drown at
sea
has it dawned on them that maybe these
migrants
want to leave the jungle and go to the
Garden of Europe
because we are doing Untold damage to
the Jungle with our Wars and our
financial imperialism wake up
and go for our daily clear
thanks president this debate is
happening against the backdrop of the
deaths of 74 people off the coast of
Italy last month half of the Dead were
children
30 are still missing
it's against the backdrop of the ongoing
criminal Trials of rescue workers and
innocent refugees for helping people to
safety it's against the backdrop of the
new Italian regulations that tighten the
Noose around the civilian search and
rescue operations who've stepped into
the breach since the EU shamefully
walked away from its legal obligations
to save lives at Sea it's against the
backdrop of the legal pushbacks violence
torture and thousands of deaths it's
against the backdrop of Gary lineker
being suspended from his job as a
broadcaster for expressing solidarity
with refugees my God what a grim
backdrop so can we please get real and
change the narrative the people coming
to the EU from outside its borders are
an asset not a threat Europe can wake up
to that fact or stay in its Savage and
ever more authoritarian debt trap I hope
for the first but fear for the second
foreign
thank you very much president
humanitarian assistance is being
criminalized the Italian government has
adopted a law which restricts
respirations
and propose this is informing the
authorities
ngos won't
won't have the time to say people in the
sea how many more tragedies will we need
to see how many more bodies do we need
to see on our beaches
at the borders of Europe this situation
needs specific measures from the
European union we need to increase the
capacities for the authorities to patrol
and we need to have you humanitarian
visas as well to allow Asylum Seekers to
come to Europe safely Europe needs to
show solidarity and save lives in line
with our values and human dignity thank
you
thank you now for the commission now I
would like to invite commissioner by
Rick McGuinness to take the floor thank
you
president good evening colleagues um
really to just thank the chamber for
putting this debate on your agenda and I
speak obviously on behalf of
commissioner Johansson I think as we
close this debate we know that this
discussion is far from over
um people get into small boats and
embark on dangerous Journeys because
there are no legal ways for them to get
to Europe and many of you have expressed
the need for safe legal Pathways and
that is something that we support let's
look at the realities of the European
union today
we reckon that in the health care area
two million professionals are needed
we also know that by 2030 there will be
7 million vacancies in long-term care
Alone
um
MEP daily mentioned that these people
are assets they're human beings with the
capacity to contribute and those who get
into boats do it putting their lives at
risk because they want something better
I also recall that this is what we call
the European year of skills
and to tell this house that we are
making progress on Talent Partnerships
with key partner countries
we're starting with Morocco Tunisia
Egypt Bangladesh and Pakistan and we're
looking at Nigeria in the near future
Our member states are fully involved and
this is really essential for success
our first round table took place with
Bangladesh on March the 1st with strong
interest from Italy and Germany to
Foster labor Mobility which should
include skills development and skill
certification
and today a Roundtable meeting is taking
place with Pakistan
just last week the first Global jobs
fair for Refugee Talent was organized in
a man this work can provide safe Avenues
and lead to jobs and opportunities
for example over 100 refugees have been
interviewed by potential employers
this is the future it's in stark
contrast to the terrible tragedies at
sea
people Smugglers
and we have to call them out people
Smugglers are to blame for these
tragedies they exploit people's dreams
they turned them into nightmares these
people end up in shipwrecks on the high
seas or in airtight vans on the highways
we think about the 18 people found dead
in a lorry in Bulgaria the people
drowned near Calabria left to die
abandoned by Smugglers who saved their
own skins
colleagues these tragedies should
Galvanize us
should Forge our determination
steal our resolved to fight the
Smugglers relentlessly by air by sea and
by land
we have to fight these Smugglers as team
Europe and with our partners to do what
we can to prevent people from getting
into The Smuggler's boats to prevent
irregular departures to work better
together to save lives
next Monday commissioner Johansson will
meet with African Union commissioner
samata High Commissioner for refugees
grandi and director general of the IMO
Antonio vittori
and this is done in our trialogue task
force on Libya and the idea behind this
is to prepare our high level dialogue
with Libyan authorities
and we have three key objectives
protecting the most vulnerable people in
detention centers including women and
children
fighting smuggling and protecting
victims stepping up on returns
evacuations through the emergency
Transit mechanism resettlement and
reintegration of migrants
I welcome the interventions today that
called for Swift progress and Adoption
of The Pact on migration and Asylum
I agree it is high time to do that and
I'm encouraged by the good progress made
by this house and by the cancer
I very much welcome the mandates you
will agree on next week we have a road
map and we are on the right track we now
need to stay on track there is a new
mood in the council a strong will to
move forward so the momentum is there
the time is right for an agreement on
this pact and together I think we should
remember that the objectives are to save
lives the figure was mentioned I think
me P Wallace mentioned a figure of
several thousand human beings whose
lives have been lost at sea and perhaps
many more thousands that have not been
counted I think we can address that
collectively Parliament Council and
commission thank you
thank you very much Madam commissioner
and let me now give the floor to the
minister Madame Roosevelt the floor is
yours
thank you madam president honorable
members commissioner
thank you for this debate
there is no doubt that the situation at
our Maritime borders must be dealt with
in an effective and timely manner in
accordance with European and
international law
let me declare a priority is to save
lives at Sea in this regard cooperation
with third countries can help to prevent
irregular departures
the EU has worked has been working
together with key Partners in North
Africa for many years with the aim to
strengthen their border management as
well as their search and rescue
capacities
this has helped to build the up
capacities for the international
protection and migration Management in
the entire region
these Partnerships are also important to
strengthen the operational framework in
partner countries in response to migrant
Smugglers
let me also say once again and this is a
clear message from this debate that the
reoccurring tragedies at Sea remind us
that a common European response is the
only way forward
we must work together to ensure a
functioning coherent and predictable
European migration policy and the whole
government approach
as I have already underlined the
presidency intends to continue in facing
a global approach to migration based on
a balance between solidarity
responsibility we have the firm will to
find a common approach and we are
determined to persuade this commitment
once again thank you for the debate and
for your attention
thank you very much Madam minister so
the debate is closed and we can move to
the next item on our agenda commissioner
statement need for immediate reform of
the internal rules of the commission to
ensure transparency and accountability
in light of alleged conflict of
interests
and I would invite Madame commissioner
McGuinness
you have the floor please